los australianos votaron por el cambio
anthony albanese líder del partido
laborista celebró su victoria en las
elecciones generales y se convertirá en
el próximo primer ministro en unos
ajustados comicios los votantes optaron
por poner fin a casi una década de
gobierno conservador en el poder
esta noche el pueblo australiano ha
votado por el camino
me siento honrado por esta victoria y me
siento honrado de tener la oportunidad
de servir como el primer ministro de
australia número 31
albanisa y reiteró su compromiso con
crear un organismo anticorrupción elevar
el salario mínimo y convertir austral en
una superpotencia de energías renovables
el primer ministro australiano scott
morrison de la coalición
liberal-nacional que gobernó el país
oceánico desde el 2013 buscaba su
reelección sin embargo reconoció su
derrota e indicó que renunciaría el
liderazgo de los liberales
esta noche hablé con el líder de la
oposición y primer ministro entrante
antonio albanese y lo felicité por su
victoria electoral esta noche se le
ve
en este país en un momento como este
cuando miramos alrededor del mundo en
particular cuando vemos a aquellos en
ucrania luchando por su propia libertad
creo que podemos reflexionar sobre la
grandeza de nuestra democracia
los laboristas ganaron las elecciones
pero no consiguieron la mayoría absoluta
en el parlamento los resultados
parciales también auguran avance para
los verdes cuyas promesas reflejan el
descontento social por la inacción
climática de la saliente administración
al bani se espera una rápida
juramentación para iniciar sus labores
dijo aspira a acudir a la cumbre de la
alianza del quad en japón el próximo
martes durante la visita de joe biden